بعد خمسه اسابيع من القصف المتواصل المياه
توقفت عن غزه فمن نجى من القذائف
والصواريخ قد لا ينجو من الموت
عطشه مط م
مخلطه خشم مازون ان ماي ان دلك في التاسع
من اكتوبر اي بعد عمليه طوفان الاقصى اعلن
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي فرض حصار شامل على
قطاع غزه هذا التهديد انعكس قصفا وتدمير
لكل مقومات الحياه لا سما ابار ومحطات
المياه التي توقف معظمها عن العمل اما
بسبب الاستهداف المباشر او بسبب نفاد
الوقود اللازم لتشغيلها فمن اين يحصل
الناس هناك على المياه طرت لشرب الماء
المالح يعني قبل ايام بسبب غياب مياه
الشرب النقص الحاد في المياه اجبر
الفلسطينيين الى اللجوء لمياه البحر
المالحه للاستحمام وغسل الملابس وحتى
للشرب احيانا رغم مخاطرها الجسيمه على
الانسان التي قد تؤدي الى الوفاه بينما
لاجا بعضهم الى العصائر والمياه الغازيه
للارتواء على الرغم من
ندرتها وقد يحصل من حالفه الحظ على لترات
قليله من مركبات التوزيع بعد السير
لكيلومترات عده والانتظار لساعات في
طوابير طويله وفي كثير من الاحيان يشربون
مياها ملوثه ع بربيش الميه هذا كل المنطقه
عايشه ي
ال ع بتشرب من البربي شاده تشير ارقام
منظمه الصحه الى ان كل فرد في غزه يحصل
على ثلاث لترات فقط من اصل 100 لتر يحتاج
اليها الانسان يوميا للشرب وتلبيه
احتياجاته الاساسيه بما في ذلك الغسل
والطهي كما نقصت المياه الصالحه للشرب
بنسبه تزيد عن 90% بحسب تصريحات السلطات
في غزه وقد بدات امراض عده مرتبطه بنقص
مياه بالظهور بين النازحين خاصه الموجودين
في مراكز الاواء المقت
لكن الى متى سيبقى هؤلاء الناس محرومين من
ابسط مقومات
الحياه